welcome back to new rock stars this is
the boys underground where we break down
and chat about amazon's darkest horrific
live-action superhero show i'm jessica
clemens here with erica woosu hey
everybody hey baby
today was the finale we finally did it
the finale of season three was emotional
we had murder uh violence come jokes and
complete betrayal uh if i say so myself
shout out to my buddy logan on writing
the finale but i also just want to know
who's whose team did you leave on
because
uh
team huey and starlight i shook them so
hard they're beautiful i love that
couple
the amount of times they break up every
they didn't break up they was fighting
they was beefing every time they
resolved it every the amount of times
they beef is enough for me to be like
maybe you guys aren't good for each
other or that's a real ass relationship
oh that's true yeah every relationship
is fighting if you're not fighting
you're not in a real relationship so you
don't really care oh god that's how you
know that's how you know i'm completely
fully teammate
um maeve wasn't uh she's in like four
episodes uh but
i just
killed a kid
they should have killed the kid they
should have killed the kid or just
knocked him out knocked him out a little
bit harder so he was asleep the entire
time and while you guys kill homeland i
mean soulja boy tried
his soldier boy and then butcher and
homelander had to get in the way
and protect the child
let's give him this recap so we can get
really into why i'm so mad so
now that homelander knows his biological
father he's become emotional and
irrational thanks to victoria newman he
goes back to ryan in an emotional plea
of family and gets ryan on his side as
people are now choosing between team
homelander and team starlight ashley and
the deep knock out maeve with some gas
and try to transport her to a new
location but bad news bears one she
wakes up and kills everyone in the
transporter van and runs free frenchie
and mother's milk are having a heart to
heart over frenchie getting the nerve
gas while butcher just knocked out huey
in a gas station and left him in the
restroom rather than taking him with
soldier boy to get more compound v his
weird way of trying to protect him i
guess uh honestly it kind of worked it
tracks
it worked and yeah it tracks and it
worked yeah a little bit because then he
woke up yeah he came and took his phone
shouldn't check his face yeah yeah
as the boys are trying to figure out
their current situation so are the seven
a train decided to see nathan his
brother who was crippled by blue hawk
nothing came of it just more stupid a
train doing more harm than good and not
listening deep in ashley are cornered by
homeland are having to answer to how
they lost maeve once homelander
confronts black noir about knowing who
his real father was he decides to rip
out a chunk of his stomach organs he
then forces the deep to kill vp prospect
lamar bishop and makes ashley take off
her wig exposing her bald scalp from her
peer pulling which was
so sad yeah i felt so bad the only time
i ever felt bad for ashley was in this
moment when she was like
i was like oh for me it was that and
seeing that she had an assistant also
named ashley i was like oh the
disrespect that's coming have you seen
the credits her name is actually also
ashley no
it says also ashley
yes ashley yes ashley it makes me want
to get an assistant named jessica um he
shows disdain to a train for killing a
fellow soup
just like five minutes after he killed
black water yo the gas lighting is
incredible that's his superpower at
first i was like oh it's because hip and
black noir are both black and then i was
like no it's because he just killed a
soup literally five minutes ago and i
had the nerve to be like how dare you a
white suit how dare he how dare you oh a
racist white soup oh
[Laughter]
starlight picks up huey and reconvenes
with the rest of the boys for a plan
they decide to stop soldier boy and
though mae found them maeve can't stand
to see homelander free so she tosses the
russian gas out the window most likely
killing a ton of people and breaks
mother milk's gun and sides with butcher
to use soldier boy to kill homelander
the room is completely divided now
soldier boy butcher and maeve go off to
kill homelander before locking the rest
of the gang in an easy to break safe
i was like that safe was also yeah it's
like she can't use her powers but i
think she's still strong starlight
starlight so it looks like yeah yeah
cause i didn't see kimiko helping yeah
she wasn't it was mainly just her
kimoko
your power is no i meant like your power
is literally just strength and you did
not help yeah
she was telling me she said nah we gotta
sit here we gotta stay here like it's a
prison uh once they reach the bot tower
we get a soldier boy versus butcher mae
versus homelander all because soulja boy
knocked out ryan the rest of the gang
jumps in to help ultimately they
recognize getting rid of soulja boy is
the best and only option because he's
about to kill everyone by imploding and
sweet sweet maeve tackles him out a
window exploding midair don't fret
because maeve survives powerless but
with the love of her life elena
homelander has ryan now butcher is dying
from temp compound v starlight is now
part of the boys and victoria newman is
the new vp running mate oh what a finale
what a what a weird finale but what i do
like about this show that the um that uh
marvel doesn't do which i i understand
maybe why is that it's so open-ended
that they have time to listen to the
audience listen to the fans what they
want because there was a lot of that
talk like daschle said about um
stormfront being the actual mom but that
we didn't see this season so they could
add that part in next season they can be
like
that's a good idea and then like ride it
in so yeah i like that open endedness
too yeah yeah i need it also it's a
breath of fresh air to be like oh it
could go anywhere now yeah um and it
also got renewed for a fourth season oh
it just got sweet sweet happy day
can't wait to see the racist child
[Laughter]
oh we are got some ads for you coming
right now uh there's a certain
confidence that comes with being
properly groomed there's an aura a vibe
you can just tell by the way they carry
themselves we call this bge big groomed
energy baby and there's only one way to
get that bge and that's manscaped we'd
like to introduce you to their best and
biggest ultimate hygiene bundle yet the
platinum package 4.0 manscaped is the
leader in below the waste grooming now
trust them with the rest join the 4
million men worldwide who trust manscape
by going to manscape.com for 20 off and
free shipping when you use the code
underground sometimes the host of the
boys underground tommy bechtold is an
avid user of the manscape platinum
package he claims he needs to be sleek
for when his past catches up to whatever
that
can you tell means
wrote this
inside this platinum package you'll find
their lawnmower 4.0 trimmer weed whacker
ear and nose hair trimmer ultra premium
body wash ultra premium two in one
shampoo conditioner ultra premium
deodorant crop preserver anti-chafing
ball deodorant crop reviver ball spray
uh toner anti-chafing boxers and the
shed travel bag to hold your goods while
traveling i actually have that bag and i
carry everything in it
it's huge it's a huge bag oh um i
you anyone can use manscaped i i love
the manscape because it also has great
cuticle care nice and we all got
cuticles and we all got you oh and you
guys all got cuticles the lawnmower 4.0
body trimmer weed whacker nose and hair
hair trimmer feature propriety advanced
skin safe technology to protect your
delicate parts and holes both are
waterproof so you can shave with less
mess get 20 off and free shipping with
the code underground at manscape.com
that's 20 off with free shipping at
manscape.com and use code underground
unlock your big groomed energy with
manscape and remember when you trim the
hedges the tree stands taller
don't scorch the earth though don't
scorch the earth oh don't scratch the
more don't sports lyrics now um let's
get into our missable details the title
of the episode is the instant white hot
wild which is volume 6 issue 38 of the
comics and the comic that follows the
origins of the female who in our series
is kamiko
who was a child fell into a vat of
compound v waste and killed a scientist
was captured and experimented on later
to be saved by butcher and team up with
the boys we get a glimpse of the divided
line between starlight the starlighters
and homelander home teamers starlight
posters framing her as 40s 50s icon
rosie the riveter believe starlight
fight like a girl and some homelander
banners reading sorry snowflake i'm with
homelander keep america safe this is
like many other moments in the show
where they're marrying mirroring reality
i bet you're wondering what that gross
mixture soldier boy just made it's milk
coke i like to call it a fancy man's
root beer float milk and coca-cola mixed
together allegedly cures a hangover but
i highly doubt it
i think i think it's like how like milk
can save a tooth like it's just an old
wise tail or it gets you to vomit the
hangover out
does he vomit no he doesn't does he
really
um it costs frenchie three bugattis to
get one dose of novichok uh bugatti can
start as low as three million so that's
an insane price he follows it with also
mentioning that he got it from like
starlight's
like bank account so oh it's okay i did
miss that detail yeah well it's okay and
she deserves it
with that money she's making from bots
she's fine while black noir is feeling
like he's about to storm the beaches of
normandy to the left we see the seven
poster with yours truly and homelander a
power couple sure why not that is until
three minutes later
uh we get a perfect shot of not only vat
petroleum of course they also own gas
but a train smooth menthol cigarettes
when will he be stopped they also have
vodify for some cool music later on
huey seems to be infatuated with pizza
rolls even bringing it up to starlight
in the car later this is a call back to
season one episode three where huey
screams at his dad exclaiming how much i
hate pizza rolls because it reminds him
of his father and how much of a loser he
was after his mom left later we find out
it didn't make him a loser at all but
his hero for staying and just being
there according to soulja boy the
soldier boy story almost beat an
american in paris for best picture at
the academy awards which i highly
doubt
first off an american in paris won six
academy awards that year uh the plus
side he got slammed jane wyman and the
coat check jane wyman was a famous
actress and was briefly married to
ronald reagan
the deep killing lamar bishop is
supposedly the first time we've seen the
deep kill anyone when i say anyone i
mean people because he certainly killed
the dolphins in season 1 episode 4
organizes the whale's boating death in
season 2 episode 3 and eats an octopus
this season
that's right gang they are destroying
cameron coleman's news desk in this shot
uh he's gonna have to find a new place
to work we're getting a flying starlight
in the comics uh starlight can fly this
is our first time seeing her do it in
the show or at least hover if you to i
don't think i want to consider this
flying but she's she's on her way she's
going baby steps she's doing iron man
when you like
the baby steps
baby steps i think she just needs a lot
of energy to be able to do that and it's
like
where you're gonna get that much energy
it's clearly electricity not the sun so
it's like yeah you gotta be in another
new studio
or a football game yeah they got a
bright friday night lights pumping in
there oh she would be
get her to texas yeah they love they
love friday night oh that's true they
love the the lights are bright vaught
news is covering maeve's courageous
sacrifice stopping soulja boy and at the
bottom of the screen reads kremlin
denies any knowledge denounces act of
terror season 3 episode four nina used
her leverage connections with russia to
find the lab in which soldier boy was
hidden clearly they're back pedaling in
russia right now the pendant butchers
holding is the same pendant he gave ryan
in season two episode eight then later
ryan threw on the ground in season three
episode three in case you don't remember
that's maeve's ex-girlfriend elena who
was last saw in season two episode vii
they've rekindled yay a downed soulja
boy statue is toppled over by
homelanders supporters just like the
beginning of season three this is how we
start season three is the seven movie
with that same statue tumbled over we
love a call back also todd is the worst
step dad to ever live i hate him someone
punch a hole through him todd is the
literal worse mother's milk get round
that up another one we need another one
is she still with him
it looks like it she's still with him
yeah i'm glad that's why i'm happy with
that mother's milk explaining to his
daughter like some heroes are bad and
she was like yeah my only hero daddy
i was like good so now when todd tries
to brainwash you again you're going to
be like my dad stay here right
my dad's the hero okay now it's time for
our big questions to get into
um so number one big question at least
for me
did homelander really kill black noir he
survived his head being split open but
not his organs being shifted a little
shifted a little bit his guts yanked out
that's just a little it's a little it's
a little scrape rub some dirt on it walk
it off you'll be fine spit on it
do you think he's actually dead uh
that's a real good question because it
did look like it and then homelander
brought in his helmet to show uh a train
in the deep uh that he was gone
and
uh a soldier boy bought it he was like
oh well okay cool you bought you you
killed him and he had reason to because
he kept the knowledge of soulja boy from
homelander so there was definitely
motive but yeah you're right we didn't
see i mean we did see him we saw that
the animated
visions fade out it didn't really fade
it backed away
did it okay either way though just
because you go unconscious doesn't mean
you're done you can't yeah you can't
wake up that's true and i also think the
way that homelander came off about it
like i killed him was more so like okay
let me see the body
like no one asked to see the body
because i think that punch in the
stomach was out of just anger for him
not telling him but i because he's
straight up said
uh black noir was more family than all
of you he was better than all of you put
together you guys are nothing i think he
still loves black noir so i think that
punch in the stomach was just out of
anger because he would have actually
like ripped his head off yeah he would
have been like i know how to actually
kill you that's a good point so i'm like
so he might still be around he might
still be around it might take him
forever to heal i mean it took him a
grip for the coma to get out of the coma
but
i'm sure with like
more compound v or with just technology
they could heal him and he could still
actually be alive i just need to see
that dead body because if you're
unconscious you can just take a helmet
off someone sure um
and it definitely makes it look like you
killed him but i don't think he's dead
like the mcu no one's ever really dead
you know
loki's died like 700 times luke is a
freaking cat at this point
no one ever dies so i i agree i don't
think black noir is dead okay uh what
does this mean
second question what does this mean for
victoria newman will she be running for
president what's her end goal here i
think her goal is power she wants to be
the new stan edgar but like president of
the united states
it's clear that she's she's running for
vp and then someone's going to kill or
so no he's just going to disappear die
accidentally head pop or whatever oh
yeah his head just explodes oh my god it
is right it is she's clearly running for
something else gunning for something
else do you think she's still working
for stan edgar
uh it's hard to say i'm confused as to
where stan edgar is like they just kind
of sent him off like in the middle of
the season i think he's just on vacation
because um he got during the whole
trial kind of thing he he didn't get
like
fired per se he just had to leave um so
i think he's on like a temp band like a
leave um so he'll come back eventually
but it's only when like
it's good to come back for him so i
think he's just like standing on the
shadows but i'm also like
stuck on victoria newman being like i'm
doing this for you i'm helping you and
i'm like
helping edgar or yeah she said she was
gonna she was doing this for edgar when
he was getting arrested she like
whispered to him and was like i need to
protect my daughter and i'm trying to
protect you or like help you
so i think
clearly she's like
maybe picking up where he left off
because he was trying to get bob singer
to get the compound v and pay more money
for it so maybe she's trying to make
more soups
maybe i mean she turned her daughter
into a suit yeah i think she turned her
daughter to a soup just to um just to
protect her when she does become
president if she dies
like she's like you can protect yourself
because they're gonna try to kill all of
you like marie antoinette style like
they're gonna kill everyone she
associates with too yeah um there's
gonna another cool offs with everyone's
heads oh yeah this is oh she is gonna
off people's heads i
i just don't i'm more confused that like
yeah she just has to be for power at
this point it's like what's
is this really a battle worth fighting
for yeah like because bmvp wouldn't
protect her any more or less from
homelander he can just bust it anywhere
and do whatever especially now that he's
lasering people's heads in public and
has his crowd of people cheering him on
so yeah i think this is a power grab i
think victoria newman is positioning
herself to be one of the most powerful
people in the world yeah politically
yeah uh so and that'll keep soups at bay
because you know you kill the president
that's the symbol vice president that's
the symbol of america do you remember
did you watch peacemaker
uh no oh it was okay i do love john cena
but
well in peacemaker there they the aliens
that came from a different planet were
coming to earth and taking it over
because they just needed a new planet to
take over and they were doing it by
taking over politicians and like
different people that were important
they were coming to earth to do that
earth is so ghetto though hey
we are
we are we're very dirty and we're dying
we're a dying star you guys so uh so
ghetto that's what they said when they
drove by they're like
roll them up they said we're going to
gentrify this yeah we're going to come
over here and i was looking for the best
uh this entire planet so i think that
was like the same situation here is like
once you get a soup in the door
all hell break loose right like and
victoria newman isn't a good person i
don't care how much she's like i'm doing
this for my daughter i'm like yeah
you're killing innocent lives she's
about self-preservation yeah she's about
self-preservation and that's what i
don't that's what i don't stand for i
third question
who speaking of homelanders zapping
people in public now who's going to
finally take down homelander this entire
season
i have been saying
this entire season
oh my god
this entire season
i've wanted homelander dead i said oh
it's going to be a crazy fourth season
when homelander's gone
he ain't gone nope if anything we got a
second one
we got a homelander in training i'm so
mad uh i'm mad but again you guys that
is how you know it's good storytelling
or it's a good show is how mad it makes
you yeah how you feel remember game of
thrones how mad cersei made all of us it
was because it was good it was a good
show just like this one i'm like
kill him kill him so who's gonna take
him down is it gonna be ryan victoria
newman the boys
see i don't know if victoria newman can
get a shot off she would have to like
sneak around real quick kind of like the
um
the
the guy that soldier boy killed in the
woods the the dude who looks in your
eyes and like yeah his mind uh i always
say mind freak
that might be his name uh it's uh oh my
gosh my i know who you're talking about
yeah yeah keep going what what
yeah it's mine storm mine yeah mind
freak i like mine freak more daschle
thank you though
he's talking about chris angel
yeah that's the one i think i i really
think and i think the audience agrees
that it's gonna be ryan ryan is the only
person now at this point
if butcher takes more compound b i'm
gonna strike him myself i will jump
through that screen i think he's done i
think he's done taking the compound v
now well here we pocketed some in that
moment where he he pushed up the the
things first uh starlight
so there's some still floating around
somewhere the thing is again you guys
are people ever really dead because in
the fourth season we could see um
i i honestly think his saving grace
butchers is the permanent compound fee
now at this point so in the next season
maybe we get the permanent soup that is
butcher um and that that that man can go
against homelander yeah but right now
it's just ryan it is just ryan to me hey
unless they unearth some other frozen
times from back in the day
please stop i don't think the boys are
now clearly going after victoria newman
and also we could see a disappeared
homelander next season because
i i'm not saying this is a good idea
but sometimes you got to give a maniac
like something to love and his thing to
love is his is ryan
so maybe he'll treat ryan like a little
cat
but he treated him like a pawn because
he brought him in to
show him to uh soldier boy and be like
hey chill out you got a grandson the
track record of how he uses his son is
so bad because also with storm front it
was just like storefront look i have a
baby and he's blonde and blue eyed and
in here it's like i need to use you to
show my dad that i'm worth something
right but then like
it
okay so if you guys hate ryan as much as
i do go back to season three episode
three where butcher literally goes off
on him and tells him like
you killed becca and you're nothing but
trash because the hurt in that child's
eyes we need to remember he is still a
child uh no wonder he lost his dad he
lost his mom and the only man that loves
him is homelander or it seems lovely
you're a child you're a child you think
this man and he's like all he cares
about is like we're soups we do this i'm
not saying i'm on ryan's side or
homelanders i'm just saying it makes it
understandable they did a good job of
making it like show that like why he
would be on his side yeah it's an
imperfect family like they
need each other or they need similar
people to themselves even though it's a
terrible fitting you know ryan should be
with butcher and the boys because that'd
be a better father but there's a
horrible dad
yes but he has glimpses of
uh you know saving and helping people he
cares about like when you punch huey in
the bathroom to keep him out of harm's
way because he reminds him of lenny his
little brother from back in the day the
tree just punches the [ __ ] out of ryan
he's like i'm doing this for you but
then that's also that's the thing i
think ryan is a double-edged sword
raising ryan at this point ungrace was
the best he could get um and he got
taken from that because now he's gonna
be raised in a bubble to think that
these people that are homelander
supporters are good people and he's
gonna be or he would have been raised
with butcher who would have left him
behind a million times to deal with his
own [ __ ]
i don't think butcher would have
butchered yell cursed him out in season
three episode three just because he
didn't want butcher to leave he he uh
smelled the weird blood on butcher he
knew something was weird and butcher was
like you killed becca and you're a piece
of [ __ ] i was like okay it's a child
it's still a child like give him the
mother's milk mother's milk would be a
great stepdad
honestly and then be like you come with
me too todd go [ __ ] off right
but yeah ultimately i think it's going
to be ryan i don't think victoria newman
um is going to even try to talk with
homelander anymore i think the boys and
victoria newman are what we're looking
for towards the fourth season
um what's next
what's next for the deep he's gonna be
jellyfish next season
[Laughter]
jellyfish krakens he's he's a weird man
the deep is almost as
comical and stupid as a train um yeah i
like a train more than the deep because
the deep is just
literally like the
dumbest
like just the worst type of dude bro
like he started off the show with sexual
assault he's a horrible person we've
hated him from the jump for good reason
and he's not now they're trying to make
him like goofy and laughable by like
having sex with sea animals but then
that's still bad he's still having
sexual assault yeah that's still
beastiality
there's nothing good
again my missable details he's killed a
lot of animals
now
he has committed treason by killing a vp
um but
i i don't know you think he's going to
stay in the seven i think so i think
he's going to remain a pawn of
homelander do you have to stay in the
good graces do you think homelander do
you think okay so uh who do we have in
the seven right now black noir is dead
dead so let's say
a train patron the deep
homelander yeah that's three out of the
seven that's yeah so they gotta do some
recruiting they gotta get four four
additional people and how many how was
your chance that you think he's going to
try to get riot he's gonna i think
they're gonna try to build a young
avengers they're gonna try building a
young
uh because stan edgar is still gone uh
ashley only reads uh homelander so and
if we're following kind of what any the
marvel or dc do they're probably going
to make a younger version team of soups
and ryan will be the leader of that
maybe also the the company is tanking
because we keep hearing little glimpses
of wat doing really badly so i think
stan edgar could come back to save the
company because clearly homelander can't
handle it what if the new bot is just uh
the the government and that's what
victoria newman is doing
because it's like
stan edgar's gone victoria no one can
vought tower is maybe like
a little a little piece it's it's a
little piece and the real pie is yeah
the world and and it just got blown up
by super treasure boys
explosion yeah that's a really good
point so i think it was just like now
people are like oh that was just like a
little bit now we want the white house
and it's like and after the white house
because now i think we can start going
along with the comics for a little nina
storyline where she stages a coup in
russia so it's like if victoria newman
works with little nina to start like to
um start a coup in russia and then
betrays nina by blowing up all those
soups heads victoria newman now just has
russia too so
so victoria newman could be playing a
big game right now
sorry that no i was like she could just
be playing a big game right now yeah and
vaught is tanking in value so newman
could come in and be like hey i'm taking
over vaught
and
because they were trying to get soups in
the military there was there was a
conversation that happened earlier in
the season so this could be a kind of
integration yes victoria newman trying
to buy compound v and own compound v but
as the vp of the country i have
i liked what bob singer was literally
because at beginning of the season is
when bob singer was like we don't need
uh soups in the army we saw what black
noir did at the hard rock cafe or
whatever the rainforest cafe he was like
that should be brought up on war crimes
so it's like i hope bob singer would be
like
let's not do it but i think victoria
newman's either gonna kill him before he
says no or
persuade him into doing it i think she's
very persuasive yeah i listened to her
also the deep's the deep's wife uh
they've broken up and she's now on like
a tour talking about the book
so the deep has a book and now she has a
book called
too deep
i can't i love the look if you like the
deep now you won't like him after this
he's eating doritos and like a cosmic
brownie on his bed uh i was so i was
like if they zoom out and there is
another fish on his penis
um just the whole starfish
god the deep is a horrible person he's a
horrible person uh i don't think anyone
watching the show was ever like the
deep's my favorite character i hope not
i want to talk to
not problematic but a red flag if you're
if if you're dating someone and they're
like my favorite character is the deep
red flags right if they're like look at
his arms though he's like nope nope get
him out of here get him out of there i'm
not trying to body shame he also has
gills
i don't body shame but if you have gills
i'm going to have to pass uh i don't
like that
that's weird that's not what you're into
yeah i guess i don't want to yuck anyone
jam but if they have gills it's probably
uh bestiality um
last and final question uh which
honestly kind of ties into what we were
talking where is stan edgar um is he
just hanging out is he vacationing i
don't know he's just like chilling
laying low kind of like nick fury is
chilling with the the scroll i can't
wait to see him in season four literally
in jamaica
just like chilling in jamaica he's
literally gonna be like did you get the
job done and victoria is gonna be like
yes
[Laughter]
yes oh so you think this is a whole long
con between the two of them it's a long
con now i think when he first got uh
arrested and like
not [ __ ] but he kicked out a vaude
wasn't i think he wasn't aware of the
plan and i feel like it's because
victoria newman was like if i showed you
the plan you wouldn't go along with it
because it takes away your title um but
now you are with it so
let's hang out and he's such a
compelling character he's like a
shakespearean
villain every time he like shows up he
has this gravitas juan carlo like he's
so good i just uh we talked about this
last episode uh
i am so tired that they don't recognize
that the root of the problem is dan
edgar and not
whatever the hell they're thinking like
the homelander and soldier boy being
like dad father i have no son i have no
blood and i'm like you guys should be
angry at stan edgar and vaught yeah and
bob why are you guys killing black noir
okay i am honestly just trying also
nothing all right
he was such a yeah i went like this when
he wrote soldier without the e
though he was like we have to kill
soldier boy is coming we have to kill he
spelled it s-o-l-d-i-r
someone take my baby
and help him out get him into some
classes i was so sad as long as he's
been alive too he just he messed up
soldier
if i was in that show i'd probably be
murdered because i'd be like oh baby you
want you want to come eat spaghettios in
my mouth
spaghetti maybe i'll take care of you
the most toxic canned food
he opens beans puts them on a plate for
imaginary animals that's true that's
true that's very true that's this
would uh uh does he eat we haven't seen
him actually he hasn't taken off his
helmet the time yeah he's back in the
jungle so um that i am still that's i
the best the biggest thing for me this
season or this episode is strictly how
uh black noir is completely uh and
definitely still alive
i am dying on that hill and i do think
that everyone's rumors and theories that
um
that stormfront is the biological mom
will come up in season four uh also we
need to remember there's okay so we we
know that um black noir we think he's
not dead that's a big theory stormfront
being the mom might show up in season
four i do truly believe that we still
have not seen huey's mom huey's mom left
him a long time ago she just left we
haven't seen anything since of her what
more triggering moment for the boys than
to have that woman show up in season
four in the mix of everything that's
happening um also i still we still need
to see victoria newman's daughter
you need to know what power she has why
she even got the compound v in the first
place i know it was to like protect her
but also
yeah and back to season two cindy the
bald patient that was in um the lab
still escaped
and we have not seen her since wow i
haven't thought about her in a minute
yeah there's a lot of still things that
are like not not plot holes just oh we
can hold on to these for later yeah and
that was one of them that i thought she
would show up in the season and she
didn't so it's like or they showed up
and they didn't so i'm like they could
show up in season four and raise hell
yeah raise hell yeah they could be part
of that kind of young avengers young
soups
thing because they were they were young
kind of bald patients almost like 11 in
them in stranger things just like a
facility full of soups who are just
being kept
kind of prisoner but underwatch yeah 100
the young avenger idea for the boys is
such a horrible idea because
i don't know about you guys but a lot of
child
brain stuff is like just being around
other children which ryan has not been
around yes he's only been around adults
so when he finally meets other soup
children he's gonna be like give me that
toy
blow their heads off yeah um also
they're okay so there's two ways this
could go he either kills a bunch of kids
when they're trying to build another
team or homelander does get tired of him
and then he ends up at the orphanage
that other soup children are at yeah i
can fully see homelander being like ill
you're annoyed you eat every day get
away from me that's the thing is like
well that's i'm not rooting for a
homeland or when i say this when soulja
boy confronted him and was like
you would have been better if you were
raised by me yeah you suck ass you're a
disappointment i think that really hit
something in him that was like i want to
raise my child the exact opposite as
that man would so he's going to overly
cuddle be overly sweet overly
sympathetic clearly we saw um in the
episode where they throw the can which
if you zoom in i think is an a train
energy drink cam that he did with the um
the in the episode where um they make
fun of kylie jenner the pepsi commercial
yes yes i think that's a trains beverage
that gets thrown
oh yeah yeah i kept zooming in and i was
like is that a pepsi can then i was like
oh that's a good miss detail yeah
i didn't put in the miss details just in
case it was but i think i'm pretty sure
it was blue yeah it was bloom i think
it's adrian so a couple things uh you
know i agree that it would be a bad idea
to do a kind of young soups initiative
in the boys because the soups we have
who are fully adults are childlike and
immature themselves yeah orgasm and
everything um and then also
was gonna say
ryan becoming a soup yeah he just needs
his ass kicked by another like super
maybe that is it yeah yeah but then it's
also what i'm nervous about is them
bullying him by accident that's true and
him getting worse
that's what i was gonna do but if they
could just like knock a few senses into
one yeah yeah yeah sometimes some people
just need to get punched one good time
to actually yeah and also not to be this
person and not hey i don't condone
violence especially to children but when
i got smacked in the back of the head i
stopped you you acted right
yeah it only took a couple times for me
to act right but so so in terms of
fathers
so
homelander is kind of being like i want
to raise ryan right because so that i'm
not what soulja boy was remember soldier
boy had that conversation with butcher
and they were talking about their
fathers and soldier boy was like my dad
called me a disappointment he said i
cheated by getting compound v or
whatever and i'm not a real man so i
always wanted to have kid i probably
have kids out there but i always wanted
to be a father so i could do better than
him but then when he got the chance to
talking to homelander he said the exact
same [ __ ] that his father said to him so
even though he had the best of
intentions of being a better father than
his own father he still was you know no
he's exuding what his dad was right so
that's what it is at the end of the day
even if you hate them you're probably
going to do the same thing
yeah even if you have every intention to
not do the same awful stuff so i think
homelander will unfortunately do similar
things he's going to do stuff that uh
stan edgar did to him just be
manipulative to ryan which he already
has been and and you know
put all his insecurities onto ryan so
this is definitely not a good pairing
cps gotta come take ryan away from home
no one in this show is a good father
also what you said made me immediately
go to the smoke except for this
is the only chaz alonzo you're doing the
lord's work you're a good father we
appreciate it i love him and he is a
good dad i always keep because there's
so many bad things in this i forget that
the light at the end of the tunnel is
mother's milk um
he definitely has other kids and i hope
we don't get to see them a soldier boy
oh okay
that line that he said he's like a lot
of rascals running around i was like oh
they acknowledged it like yeah they left
the door open yeah
i also know offense but he lies clearly
uh when we see that uh flashback of him
um
uh
liberating uh wasn't it or something
yeah yeah liberating people i was like
okay he probably showed up a week
afterwards or
just had it staged so and they confirmed
it yeah and he's probably lying about
how many times he's had sex with people
i don't think he's affecting everybody
but if he did there's definitely
miniature versions there's homely under
brothers everywhere brothers and sisters
but i don't think we're gonna get that
in season four that would be so much to
hit um we still have russia we still
have little nina we saw victoria newman
we saw stan edgar we still have a dead
suit black noir i just don't know maybe
he did he ain't dead but i think that's
so much that's gonna hit in season four
um going forward and also i'll be doing
a breakdown of the entire season and
going into where the franchise will lead
so swipe yeah it's gonna be great andrew
our kill count with eric okay here we go
first kills are maves when she breaks
out of her prisoner transport killing an
anesthesiologist the driver and three
armed guards homelander punches through
our baby boy black noir r.i.p maybe the
deep kills vp in the pool kimiko kills
five vaught guards and homelanders zaps
a guy who throws a can at ryan so that
makes our totals uh maeve with five
kills kimiko with five kills the deep
with at least one kill and home lander
with two kills for a total of 13 kills
this episode now shout out to akron
goddess on twitter who requested a
complete kill count for this entire
season you know i got you so adding up
the 13 from the season finale uh and all
the previous episodes the kill count for
this season of the boys is
85 kills ooh a cool 85. i think that's
still an a
i've been out of school for 10 years
does it show and also did i ever get an
a
i'm used to getting 63. so you guys that
is a lot of kills that's not a
phenomenal amount of numbers you might
not think it's a lot of numbers but uh
if we saw 85 that means there's 400 off
screen at least at least unconfirmed
kills uh also we're not acknowledging it
and they better acknowledge in season 4
may throw in that
nerve gas oh she probably impaled
somebody impaled went off kills 14
people like i'm sure maybe this actually
killed like 32 people this episode
and that is it for our boys underground
after show you guys follow me on twitter
and instagram and everywhere as lulu uh
clemens follow eric wusu what's your
what's your handle
kid at a wusu kid uh following rockstars
everywhere hit that like notification
bell make sure you uh follow us on all
platforms uh check out our merch options
they're great and keep an eye out for
this weekend we have a lot of breakdowns
for thor 11 thunder by eric and voss we
have our stranger things two breakdown
from whitney van laningham and next week
you'll get my entire season three rap
very short season three rap what we can
expect in the franchise the season four
of the boys can't wait to give that to
you have a nice night don't be too mean
to children because you saw this episode
like me i texted my nephew and i said
you're the exact same age as ryan i
gotta fight you
or i love you good night i love you good
night
if i if julius if you're watching this
square up baby have a nice night you
guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you